thank you very much thank you pop on for
the invitation it's I'm 30 to be here
and this is my first time at you I you
know I've heard a lot about the
University I've heard a lot about the
course so I'm obviously very excited to
be here and when Pavan I talked to us
that a few colleagues of mine I know you
met Andy Rosenberg last last week oh
actually this week when he talked to us
and we were discussing the things that
we were going to be talking here today
you know my role would be to talk about
chapter 5 which is payment for ecosystem
services and I my current position at
sea I am a scientist that works a lot
with ecosystem services valuation and
mapping and looking into the landscapes
and how we can inform the feud
activities that we have so for that
reason I'm going to give you I'm going
to try to give you a flavor of what the
science the appliance applied science of
bio of ecosystem services is for a large
organization like ours and how we
implement some of these activities in
the field the hurdles that we face the
challenges but also the successes that
we've we've had in the last 10 years or
so so so let me start by whoops so this
is um yeah let me start by talking about
a little bit of the outline of this
presentation today I'm going to talk a
little bit about our work at
Conservation International and the
reason why we care about the science and
implementation of ecosystem services
I'll be focusing the next few slides on
the science of napping ecosystem
services and valuing ecosystem services
for with a specific goal of informing
policy and decision making processes and
our implementation in the field and then
I'm going to be talking about some of
the tools some of the cutting edge edge
tools that we are working to do this and
and then at the very end of the
presentation I'm going to address some
of our field experiences some of you
know a scaling up of activities from the
very local level to a more national
level of implementation and some of the
successes that we have obtained in the
last year's so let me start talking
about CI we were founded in eighteen
nineteen eighty seven and historically
our main goal has been biodiversity
conservation and we've done a lot in the
last over 20 years working with that but
in the last few years I think out of
award is that though we did feel that
quite a lot of was accomplished we also
realized that there was much more to be
done and extinction rates continue to
grow and you know we would only get so
much done if people weren't aware of the
importance of ecosystem services for
their own livelihoods for their own
well-being so a few years ago in a major
change for the organization we changed
our mission to one there is a more
encompass encompass of human well-being
in a sense that our needs come a lot of
our needs come from nature and unless we
care and protect nature and ecosystem
services we are very much undermining
the health of the planet in our own
health so that's that's very much you
know the that what's driving the
organization now we are working very
much with security as we are looking to
climb at fresh water food health
security so it's a big big shift for an
organization that it was as I said
before focused on on biodiversity
conservation and one of the impetus was
also the report that came just a couple
of years ago in the in this
mirror of discussion about the role of
ecosystem services and for the purpose
of of conservation of nature
conservation this report was done for
the baton Gordon Moore Foundation and
basically what they said is that
although very promising the concept of
ecosystem services had really a long way
to go in terms of getting standards and
robust methodologies for for assessment
and unless we did that we really
wouldn't have the concept internalized
in all levels of decisions in all
economic sectors so this was you know an
important conclusion of a you know a
report that made all of us even more
aware of the challenges that we faced
and but also in you know had very very
positive note that it is a very
important concept and it is one concept
that a lot of conservation is a lot of
researchers are very enthusiastic about
and it hasn't it has the great potential
of changing the way we do biodiversity
conservation so speaking about the
standards of measurement so what are the
difficulties that we face one thing
about ecosystem serves is that is that
they are not homogeneous you know they
are very heterogeneous and they also
evolve with time so both in space and in
time they defer they have very specific
characteristics and so they require us
to look into not only where the biome
biomes are but look into a
climatological issues geomorphological
issues so it's a fairly complex science
of looking to different ecosystem
services this you know basically the
location is is driven the location of
those biomes is primarily driven by
energy flows and at this
same time so unless we really understand
the specifics of the different ecosystem
services in terms of how they occur in a
space and how they flow most importantly
in a space then we won't have a good
grasp of the services in how they reach
humans and how they provide for the
benefits that we are talking about so
one of the things that it's really not
that Neil but it's a steal of a problem
and it is to a hurdle that we face is
that in trying to look into different
ecosystem services and see how these
ecosystem services reach the
beneficiaries in this diagram here that
i'm showing you can see that in the
number one quarter there you have the
provision and the benefits occurring at
the same site at the same space in the
same cell for example this is let's say
provisional you know provisioning
services like food service where or
subsistence agriculture where the
services are there the population are
they are there comes the services reach
there cuz the beneficiaries at the same
unit at the same spatial Union in the
second one you have this provision that
occurs at a certain space but it has a
much broader impact it's like the case
of global services like as the climate
regulation the role of forest for
example in regulating the climate so
it's a more omnidirectional benefit in
the third one you can see for example
where the services flow downhill this is
the case specific of water for example
you have florists upstream that have an
important role in controlling flow and
quality of water as an example and the
last one you have say coastal services
like think of wetlands coastal wetlands
to Ares who's the provision occur at a
very edge
but the benefits are reaped two words
you know the other side one direction of
benefits so this is really what we need
to keep in mind for different services
and this is what we started looking to
and thinking about how do we go about
and map there's in a landscape in an
area that we care about how do we look
into whether there are similar synergies
between biodiversity other services how
do we look into where are the best areas
to invest considering that we have
limited conservation funding and we want
to be efficient and cost-effective we
wanna you know we have so much funding
we really need to address the areas that
are under the highest threat and we also
need to address the areas on which we
can afford to work you know so what we
did is we started mapping in the island
of Madagascar a very important high
biodiversity mega biodiversity area
which has a tremendous amount of
deforestation less than fifty fifteen
percent of the forest remains in the
country so we looked into Madagascar and
thought our their Synergy's what do you
know can we see biodiversity Kirko
occurring with other services so we
looked into biodiversity and the next
thing we looked we're a climate
regulation in the form of biomass both
above and below ground was was provide
was was found and remember this is a
service that's omni-directional so
really where it occurs it where you know
it's distributed evenly across the globe
the next thing we looked into was water
that the very specific case where really
it's a benefit that addresses the needs
local population so we now are modeling
we look into areas downstream that were
dependent on water both for you know
consumption household consumption as
well as for rice padding so we were
looking for quality of water water free
of sediment so these is the results you
see the the red areas are areas that are
very important for the provision of
water services downstream the next thing
we looked into was so now we see there
is biodiversity there is climate there
is water can we bundle them you know
these are you know areas where you can
find a certain level of the provision of
these two services plus vs. certain are
certainly areas you want to look into
investing your conservation funding so
these were there is the eastern fringe
of Madagascar that's where most forest
text is the primary remaining forests
access these are the areas that are then
where we can bundle the ecosystem
services the next thing is we looked
into was which are the areas with
highest threat which areas if we model
the forest station for the next
quality not the quantity we did look at
both water quality and quantity I where
I focus on quality but but yes we did
look into quantity as well because the
population down streams are dependent on
the flow yes the question was whether we
looked into quantity or just quality we
looked at both the next is next step of
the analysis is where the highest threat
is found because those are the areas
where we want to address our Air Force
and this is the results of our probit
model on the highest levels of different
station note that it doesn't really
occur on the eastern fringe but we found
it more like on the western fringes of
madagascar the next thing for us is okay
so we want to add the concept of
additionality I'm sure all of you have
heard about that it's a very important
concept is like is an area where you
want to act because otherwise the
benefit will be lost in terms of the
provision of the consistent service it's
a concept that it's used a lot in the
REDD+ mechanism so areas on which if you
don't prevent deforestation those areas
are most certain to to disappear as a
result of deforestation so we bundled
this we overlaid or we multiply the
results we had from the bond of services
with the high threat areas in the last
step in the analysis was to look into
the areas which essentially an
investment the opportunity cost would be
too high for us to to to to meet so what
we did is we subtracted the high
opportunity cost which in the case of
madagascar is primarily cash crop for
exports so we subtracted those areas for
the analysis and the results that we
have here is basically where are the
efficient in terms of addressing
deforestation and cost-effective areas
for implementation of
share schemes potential payment schemes
in reviewing the chapter 5 as i'm sure
you have you notice that one of the main
issues in implementing a payment scheme
is they oftentimes the lack of targeting
the lack of you know the targeted from a
spatial perspective in terms of other
services provided is there a threat that
we can address so this kind of exercises
exercise is a preliminary step that
addresses this question of course there
are other institutional issues or their
socio-economic issues that really need
to be looked into and I'll talk about
those eventually but this is just an
example of how we went about now I'll
talk very briefly about one exercise
that we did in terms of looking to
values like this in this case we are
looking to global values of ecosystem
services we are looking into one area
that is relatively new for for me
personally is like coastal and marine
services we normally focus a lot of
terrestrial services we are now doing a
study that addresses the global values
of Fisheries recreation tourism and
shoreline protection these results of
this analysis they have just been
finalized have just being produced but
what this kind of analysis show using
different methodologies is that some
areas are really have very very high
values in which we want to focus our
efforts on and that has you know some
implications for policies in terms of
let's say in the case of fisheries where
the benefits go and where you know
whether local people are getting those
benefits I'm not going to really dwell
very much into that because whoops
because in the main purpose of this you
know addressing the issue of valuations
as i'm sure you already have seen before
in the presentations before is that the
valuation remains a fairly controversial
issue and as you all know but one that
is extremely necessary because when you
make decisions you really rely on
information there there's no perfect
information there is no perfect world
but you really really have to have a
minimum amount of information so we do
valuation at a global level to have a
good picture of how you know what the
main areas and oftentimes we dwell Vince
to some specific areas to look some
specific countries to see you know what
the values are for the local economy but
the main point of this is just to tell
you that this is all very well an
interesting but you know what is the
utimate goal what is a huge net goal of
evaluation exercise its decision making
and how do you go about you know what
kind of information and what kind of
decision-making what kind of indicators
can help us to really incorporate the
natural capital values into these
indicators that are more widely accepted
in a wee economies ecologists we often
provide single you know point site
analysis or global analysis that I just
described but they remain what this knee
remain a study that was done that showed
the value of these ecosystem services
provided by that biome is such the
challenge now is how to move on into
this macro economic indicator that will
tell you that the you know the natural
capital values need to be incorporate so
we get more and more aware of how
resources are being degraded and
we get more and more aware of our
dependence on natural capital and what
we currently have in our micro economic
system is it's just a matter of the main
micro economic indicator is GDP which is
a broad measure is the value of all
marks and the market goods and services
in innocent in a country in one specific
time but these GDP has enormous
limitations and one of the limitations
is it doesn't address distributional
issues as we know it doesn't address the
issue of the degradation of natural
capital as it does with other physical
capital so in order to overcome that one
of the potential alternatives is looking
into incorporating natural capital
values or you know specifically of
ecosystem services international
accounting system and there are quite a
few initiatives that are doing that one
important initiative that I hear you're
going to discuss that in more detail
eventually but I'm going to just briefly
introduce is their World Bank wealth
accounting and valuation of ecosystem
services that is led by the word bank
and partnership with a number of
organizations and is piloting these
exercises in in six countries Columbia
Madagascar the Philippines are just a
few of them and next working very
closely with the United Nations SIA
which is the system of environmental and
economic secound is trying to set up the
standards for incorporation of ecosystem
services values international accounting
this is all to introduce you to the work
that we are doing in Madagascar again
under the scope of wealth we're looking
into one very important area in
Madagascar which has the acronym
us and doing an assessment on the by
physical and monetary values of
ecosystem services and looking into how
from a site level analysis we can
upscale those values to a national level
system so this is a very preliminary
study of heading to Madagascar next week
for a feud activity feud data clattering
collecting and talking to a lot of
policymakers about their needs and
looking to how they have managed so far
to implement some of the payment
freaking system services schemes and
some of the lessons learned with the
idea that we can get using one modeling
tool we can then produce by physical and
monetary values of ecosystem services in
Madagascar so moving on one of the tools
that we are using you Madagascar into a
great extent this is helping us to see
the validity of using that tool is Ares
I'm sure many of you are familiar with
some of the tools that we currently have
for mapping and valuing ecosystem
services they work that I am showed
before does not rely on any of those
tools they're basically results of a
statistical and in our own modeling
hydrological model included using
important GIS data important land based
information with those tools that we
have and the three of the most prominent
tools are invest mimes and Ares we can
do in a more effective in a more
systematic way assessment and valuation
of ecosystem services let me start with
invest
and I just have to to say that my work
is with Ares so I'm going to focus a
little bit more on areas but I can see a
little bit about the three of them I'm
somewhat familiar with with the three of
them eros is a natural capital project
which is led by Stanford the Nature
Conservancy in the World Wildlife
Foundation and it's a very prominent to
in a sense that it uses spatial modeling
it uses basically it's a set of tools
that is very modular you can do
different things you can add or you can
build as you go and those models are
deterministic with which means that
they're basically based on equations
there are algorithms as we like to call
that determine the provision of a
service in a specific landscape using
GIS based information so this is
available on this website too and what
you do is you download the system and
it's the premise of invest is that it's
a decision-making tool that allows for
policymakers and decision-makers to see
different scenarios that are primarily
based on land cover change so think
about a forest vs are known forest areas
you know for say a proper infrastructure
or you know any any kind of mega change
or making structure structural project
or infrastructure project so this is
what invest can be used for again you
can its modular in a sense that you can
do hydrology if you were to focus only
on hydrology or you can do other
services they have quite a number
climate regulation pollination and they
have quite advanced a quite a number of
models again this too is is a model that
rely
eyes on algorithms and the requirement
to do an assessment on a specific areas
basically that you do understand GIS you
have a you know basic to intermediate
level of GIS and also that you need to
get the data set that the mod the
modules require so it's it's quite of
intensive in terms of data sets needs
which are GIS layers of datasets very
interesting to they have case studies in
many parts of the world is a prominent
to mimes is it's a static to so you see
things now you have linked over change
you can see what the results is but it's
like the scenarios are static mines on
the other hand is a dynamic model it is
based on seemly which is also
deterministic also based on algorithms
and what you do is you have to have a
very good understanding and it's this is
a university of your mon model led by
the gun institute for ecologico nomics
and almost all models for all week Oh
system services are developed it can
also be modular and under you have a
library of models but it requires that
you do have a fairly good understanding
of modeling in order to get an
assessment of a certain area it also
requires a significant data set and I
think one of the most limitation is
computational power it really is
demanding because it's run on a cell by
cell basis so it you know the home auto
runs and in a cell and the flows are
determined a currently so it's it's a
more is a more say sophisticated in a
sense that it requires a good
understanding of modeling and then there
is Ares Ares is the result of a National
Science Foundation grant that we got a
few years ago and Ares is
exactly a motto he is basically i'm done
with Bayesian networks and it's not
based on algorithms like the other two
it basically uses in intelligent systems
to build specific models as you go it's
also available on the web and you can
basically select in a specific area of
interest and then do an analysis the
caveat is early Aries is a tool in
development so there are many models
that are created but it's not certainly
not as well advanced as invest in terms
of easy access you will have to go and
you have to work most certainly would
have to select you could select an area
and you most certainly if you're very
serious about doing an analysis with
areas you most certainly would probably
need some guidance to ore some you know
fairly good understanding of how you
could do that we have a number of case
studies I'm just trying to convey the
message that this is to is in
development and it's probably the most
cutting-edge to amongst all the other
tools so it's certainly more
sophisticated in SS go healthy is
amazing network yes
the question is the about the robustness
of the models in terms of whether it
depends on the inputs I think that's
true for all modeling on tools to a
great extent but in the case of Ares i
think the uniqueness of Ares is the fact
that it has a probability a function
that will allow you to run the motto
irrespective of you having data for
specific parameters with the other two
models that we were discussing if you
don't have data for a certain parameter
for that is crucial you basically won't
be able to run your model with Ares
you're able to run your model but your
results will have a certain
probabilistic result will have the level
of certainty or uncertainty is higher
and so you know for the other two models
remember they are deterministic which
means that the results are the results
and so it's a matter of you to trust
whether you know the algorithms of the
motto are correct another question
allows you to work with different ears
first year the most basic line in the
movie eight getting information basic
training positions and then you have not
appeared less than them and Oliver and
you can go back and forth that is true
the question was the invest has a
Mortier approach or characteristic if
you will and so you can choose the level
of complexity as you can choose the two
modules that you work as well and invest
also for the cheer to which has been
released and not too long ago you can
also do economic valuation of certain
services it's not unlike some models
it's not benefit transfer the economic
valuation there is it's more production
function approach than then other models
in any case I can move on and talk a
little bit more about areas are there
any other questions yes I'm just a brief
question about disability functions is
that based on Monte Carlo a markov chain
monte carlo cultures I wouldn't know now
I'm not you know I'm not the person
who's doing the modeling of it I can put
you in contact the question was whether
it's based on Monte Carlo I wouldn't be
able to answer that question my I'm you
know of all of these three models I have
to say that a probably worked a lot more
with the mimes approach a copy I on Ares
but it doesn't mean that I'm working
with the modeling process i'm working
more with the applications of it ok so
moving on we do have a few
characteristics i think that will better
explain what ares is about first of all
it's
so let me go back okay it's basically
it's a toolkit and it's not a single
model as I said it's not deterministic
and it's based on an intelligent system
which means that the data it's based on
what we call you know it's based on our
latest understanding of ecosystem
services and the variables that are
important for the provision of a certain
ecosystem service and so there is a lot
of background information but once the
data sets are in we are talking about
globally available datasets in this case
the motto has an ability to learn from
the datasets and to establish through
Bayesian networks to establish the
correlations so no algorithms either I
think the most unique thing of Ares is
there its ability to not only address
the provision which is what the other on
tools offer but also the benefits and
how they put system services flow in
space remember this was the very core of
my talk how do you address that how do
you avoid the spatial mismatch in terms
of provision of benefits that's by far I
would say the best characteristic of
Ares they are models allow for the flow
of ecosystem services in a certain
landscape which means that we can assess
how they reach beneficiaries another
thing is that we just discussed is the
fact that is a probabilistic model so
there is a degree of uncertainty
associated with that so our the results
of the two are not you know a single
number but rather you know it will
provide you a range within a certain
value that the the results are in all of
those results like the other model
there are spatially explicit results
naturally and you can see maps of it it
is is a web-based is not proprietary it
basically can be accessed by anybody
remember it's a tool in progress so the
computational power of it is still
somewhat limited and so we basically
work on a series of case studies and
like I said the example in Madagascar
will use ares tomorrow the biophysical
flow of ecosystem services in the
indicas area so this is at the core of
ares this is the the conceptual
framework is you see in this green area
over here you have a bio of a certain
area which provides ecosystem services
with let's call it the provisioning
regional region the beneficiaries of
those services let's say for the sake of
example are downstream there let's talk
about non-rival use region and so as the
sit as the ecosystem services flow in
space you can have some sink regions
which can be a good thing or bad thing a
sink region for example when you
interrupt the service when you build a
pipeline through here and need to rip
the services certainly a bad thing a
sink region when you provide for
retention of segments on the other hand
can be a good thing but that's the
concept that ecosystems flow and
services come not you know it's not from
the purpose of decision-making it's not
only important to find out where the
services are provided but rather where
they reach beneficiaries moving on so
this is another way to express that
let's think about it the landscape and
these are pictures in Madagascar where
you can see provision of services of
biodiversity in a certain landscape and
you can see you know the activities
there are dependent
those services being right spelling or
ecotourism so these are the areas where
the beneficiaries are located and so we
need to model the flows between the
provision and the services and how they
reach the beneficiaries so this is
definitely a spatial modeling as added
best so because like i said before
different services will have different
ways that they flow in a space for
example hydrological services they
basically they follow a well-established
hydrological models and and so you know
that depends on the topography of the
region for static view sheds for example
the view of a mounting it's basically
the line of sight how you can see it for
climate regulation is omnidirectional
which means basically a service provided
here benefits the entire globe and for
recreational is more like a curve kind
of function that the further you are
away from the service then the the lower
the benefit is for you so here you have
one specific for example output of Ares
and this is the project sound in
Washington State and what you can see
here is a critical flows of services so
think of this area on on the left hand
side where you can see there are just
very this read the contours circles that
determine which areas are really
critical for the provision of services
and in which any effort should be made
to leave that area relatively intact or
even enhance the services of enhance the
protection of that area so the closer do
you get into this contour to the red
circle areas these are the areas that
any
disturbance in those areas would
basically create the major disturbance
in the flows of services for a number of
beneficiaries this is important because
suppose you citing a pipeline over here
so you certainly you want to avoid the
critical area so there are ways that you
can plan to avoid the critical areas of
of services flow this is another example
that we had four areas in Madagascar
that focus more on fisheries or
subsistence fisheries and what we did in
the first map was to look into the
demand in terms of coastal populations
that are war dependent on subsistence
fisheries and I apologize it's really
hard to put maps on on powerpoints and
at least in a way that you can see the
details but i'll be very happy to if
should you be interesting and getting
better maps for you in the second one we
have a fraction where the demand is met
on which people have access to the
fisheries and in the last one we have
where the demand is not met for a for a
number of reasons you know segments
could be a reason lack of access could
be a reason excess population could be a
reason but if all to say that with a
tool like that you really can pinpoint
areas that are important on the way or
on where you know we need to look very
carefully and see what's going on so
like many other tools this is a first
approach to understand at the landscape
level where the issues are but as I said
before for policy and decision making
process you certainly need to go one
step ahead and look into other
socio-economic context institutional
factors presence of absence of
government etc this is the result of one
case study that we
in Veracruz Mexico and that also
illustrates we're different you know the
different needs by different sectors are
only different populations but here you
can see the man of water this isn't it
an area where there is a water scarcity
and there are conflicts with respect to
water uses so we looked into this area
we looked into the different conflicting
needs from agriculture aquaculture
industry residential and we could find
out what the demand was and then doing
analysis on a an Aries analysis looking
to where the flows to beneficiaries
where and then the results which were
basically sources that could be usable
sources that where you had surface water
but sources that you basically didn't
have access to water you know basically
because a surface water was not present
or you know any of those issues we most
of the hydrological models that we work
are essentially based on surface water
ground water remains a very difficult
issue to address there are no data sets
so these are data sets a lot of those
data sets behind here we're customized
working with in a call which is a
Mexican agency and some of the local
stakeholders we did a fairly a good
participatory process with them we did
the bottles we worked with them in
getting the data we went to talk to them
about the preliminary results we are now
and in the process of getting the
feedback incorporating incorporated into
India analysis
the this is where basically there is no
water a water that can be accessed it's
either groundwater but it's you can't
really reach or it's not on own surface
water or people do not have access to
water in this region I'm sorry I should
have here on diagram but i think the the
red the red the areas are more critical
areas these are the areas where you face
is car city of water so from yellow to
green this is and on the blue lines here
this is higher area so they are probably
you know there is a little bit more
excess of water here then then further
down
I'm sorry no this is basically there's
no issue of infrastructure here this is
basically we're talking about water
flows in the landscape and water needs
and where water meet the demand or where
it doesn't meet the demand I'm staring
on the question go ahead please it yeah
I'm sorry this you would need to see the
maps and I agree that the color scheme
the possible source is where you could
essentially there is a potential for you
to reach that all that water but for
some reason you don't the actual source
is where there is water there and you
can reach that and you are reaching that
you are using for some conception being
that industrial agriculture or human
consumption household consumption what I
think one of the results of the study
was the differences in terms of what the
needs war and in terms of what the
demand was so the conflict is you know
whether water is taken for a specific
use in a certain area let's say
industrial use and will leave less for
local populations that kind of this kind
of conflict so you can see where in the
landscape you can see where this water's
these the water is using used for
different purposes and demand is met or
unmet okay so we do have quite a few
case studies that we have developed and
in different stages of development i'd
say probably Washington State Madagascar
are fairly well developed in terms of
the services veracruz is also had a very
strong focus on
so it's it's fairly well developed in
that sense as well but it's a tool that
has very limited of funding as well and
it's a 2 as I said I'd like to stress
that is a tool that is being in the
process of being developed so there are
a lot too there is a long way to go I've
been talking about those tools tomorrow
but I think I didn't want to just you
know give the impression that you know
you really have to have a lot of
technical expertise or that technical
background to do those ecosystem
services which is often you know what
happened you have a group of people who
are fairly familiar with modeling or
fairly familiar with the use of GIS in
some cases you do when you can't do that
in other areas you really can rely on
other important tools that are available
and there are also based on spatial data
sets on remote sensing data and those
tools they know they're not ecosystem
services they can be very informative of
where degradation occurs and I would
like to point the fire risk in the fire
alert system as tools that are very
important in our Feud activities and the
illegal logging and encroachment also as
a tool that it's very important in the
use of protected areas and red plus
sites so these are tools that you can
look online and you can subscribe to the
service and you can as a manager of a
certain area in a remote area you can
monitor either fire occurrence of fire
or the risk of fire and you can also
monitor encroachment which is really
very important it's not available in our
countries but our efforts are focused on
mostly tropical areas Madagascar
Indonesia believe in Peru
for example for the fire alert system
for the fire risk is a more global to
illegal logging at the moment is
currently restricted to protected area
in red blood sites and you really get
amazing feedback from the use of those
tools because it really threw a
subscription service of the tool you can
really get an alert in a form of an
email you can act so you know like I
said there are different tools they have
different purposes and they are always
very helpful especially for Forest
Service of the countries who have very
limited capability to monitor that and
to enforce the law I will wrap this up
recalling what I said at the beginning
with the lack of standards and the lack
of monitoring tools the lack of decision
making tools which what what was our
dressing before so we are currently now
working with a bunch of a group of
organizations and scientists into
developing some standards for the
regular monitoring of ecosystem services
we do have a site in interns any year
which is what I'm showing here in which
we are developing and testing metrics
for ecosystem services tools agriculture
livelihoods and climates this is very
much working progress and at the very
early stages and but we are in the
process of negotiating upscaling this to
the African continent and the global as
well hopefully with support from the
Gates Foundation so this is very
exciting work I'd like to shift gears
now and talk more about payment fergus
system services I spent quite a bit of
time talking about the science of
because there's some services and the
tools let me talk about one important
portfolio of projects that we have that
is called conservation stewards program
which
we have in nine countries with over 50
projects they are essentially agreements
with communities to protect biodiversity
in exchange for economic benefits
sometimes in in the form of livelihoods
improvements sometimes in the form of
cash payments they vary but so we
through this project it's really quite
amazing we do have like I said over 50
brushes and I think we reach out more
than 3,500 people around the world with
this project oftentimes working with
communities one of the projects that we
had was in Ecuador called gran reserva
chachi we work with worked with three
indigenous communities and we provided
basically monetary compensation for
benefits which were commonly agreed upon
by the communities and in exchange for
enforcement and protection of a fairly
small area seven thousand hectares in
the Chaco region and you know building
the this project and I think one of the
papers that you had explained very well
the all of these projects required not
only a lot of studies to find out what
the benefits are you know at a minimum
in terms of biodiversity conservation if
not ecosystem services but a lot of
building trust a lot of negotiation a
lot of this is these are contracts these
are agreements in which we the
communities and conservation
organizations like ourselves they enter
into into a contract to do that so we
did that with a number of partners we
often work with several partners we you
know have a great number of partnerships
around the world and the this was just
you know a few years back when this was
going on people would say well that's a
fairly small project this is kind of you
know very low-key but the importance of
this project it's really
either it provided the foundations for a
much broader payment scheme that is now
being implemented social in the program
so see boskie in Ecuador so Ecuador is
now has this project that reaches quite
a number of people impoverished
communities and it's very much for the
purpose of biodiversity conservation
also is one of the strategies of the
climate strategy of the country in terms
of maintaining the carbon stocks in the
area and it's a fairly ambitious project
and so far fairly successful as well I
think thus far they have reached
something like you know I can't remember
what the numbers were but you know
thousands of people have already applied
and I already receiving the benefits I
think something like eight points 85
million already was a span of this
project and its really has a lot of the
social goals political goals if you will
that many other projects don't have
specific with the target of addressing
poverty alleviation so this is a fairly
unique project in many ways and one that
we have great hopes for so far has been
quite successful as I said I will go on
and talk about reduced emissions for
from this for deforestation and forest
degradation we do have also a good
portfolio of 20 projects and more than
20 projects there either in the process
of being implemented or they are in the
process of being designed and they are
spread all over the world and our main
role in those projects oftentimes we
work very closely with the government
this projects are implemented by the
government is to provide the technical
capacity and the ability of those
countries
to implement both by being ready to
implement their climate regulation
strategies to implement their base lines
with very solid robust methodologies
that we established what the emissions
are expected to be and also training
people in the field to do that building
capacity in those countries so this is
an example of for example the kind of
mapping a kind of modeling that we do to
both find out where deforestation is
being historically occurring in to model
to predict the future deforestation in
the absence of the project so we do that
allows us that you know rigorous
scientific assessment that follows
approved upon standards allows us to
work closely with this community's Peru
Colombia Panama Kenya PNG in Cambodia
are in the process of having feasibility
studies of working at the project
description and design of this this
documents and in you know doing further
research on the advantages of reduced
emission of dispersed station and
degradation that's also very important
as a very important convincing argument
there is a tool that I won't be talking
about but you you please do take a look
at skol Osiris that allows national
governments to play with different sets
of redd+ designs to find out the
economic benefits for their country and
in this case in for example we have a
very good study in Indonesia that shows
very clearly what the economic benefits
are let me talk about Madagascar once
again because this is an area on which
we have put in put a great effort in
addressing the issue of degradation as i
said before being working
Madagascar for many many years now and
in 2003 the president committed to
triple the areas of protected area and
the country from you know the current
levels then and so that meant that we
working with the government we were able
to going through a very important
participate or approach determine the
design of this large landscape area on
which we would focus air force to
prevent deforestation creating a major
protected area that would encompass a
mosaic of different land uses some with
strict conservation and some that were
on which human uses were allowed so this
is what Cass is about in the light blue
areas are formally protected areas and
either national parks or reserves so we
have here this is probably one of the
largest rainforest them tracks in in the
country with an amazing biodiversity in
terms of the species that are found
nowhere else endemic species and
particularly lemurs which are fairly
threatened that has also a fairly large
population density that relies on
livelihoods that are slash and burn
agriculture primarily some other as well
some other gradation issues are
resulting of my knee logging hurt
hunting & Wildlife so working this area
we were able we are able to design this
red plus which has the purpose of
reducing emissions but allowed to really
this area to be effectively protected
and implemented the cast area we are
working with the World Bank which has
committed to buy some advanced as a
purchase and I'd advanced emission
reductions from the area but most import
and think about this and most important
message is that this is only working
because we are working with a management
system that really allows for great
participation from the design of the
area to the decision level making
process that involves local communities
so it's it's really rather impressive
you have from the highest levels of the
government from the minister to the
manager of the area to the population
living in the different sectors who not
only have employment opportunities
livelihood opportunities but also have a
saying in the design and implementation
of the project and I think that's
basically probably the only way for
these activities to succeed is to have
you know buying in by the local
communities a participatory approach
that allows two people to voice their
concerns and their needs we are also
working very hard on building capacity
as I said before we have trained a good
number of people what you're showing
here on this picture is just the
training a couple of weeks ago in
Madagascar and we are now doing a
university level course similar to what
you have here on red plus in Madagascar
I'm going to now is rep a little bit the
stock talking about our lessons learned
a couple of years ago a colleague and I
did a review of our initiatives on
ecosystem services and payment for
existing services schemes around the
world and we really found some very
interesting lessons and insights from
our portfolio first we really realize
that we really need more science we
really many of these schemes that you
come across are you know a lot of them
are based on assumption you see that in
the literature
so you really need to address more you
know the issues of provision benefits
additionality and we certainly hope that
the exercise we did can can shed light
into that we need more spatially
explicit tools I think they are becoming
more and more available but they're
still fairly sophisticated in fairly
complex we need to make sure that we can
using those tools convey the message in
a clear compelling way you know with
with the robust science that we want to
see but in a way that allows for the
impact to be more easily observed we
need to really care and address social
economic and ecological context I think
we as scientists we very much focus on
the biophysical and economic side but
not so much on the social i think
participatory approaches have proven to
be critical and quite important in the
success of the into this agreement so as
is the stakeholders participation that i
hope i have emphasized again we really
need a lot of science we need to tailor
for the different context each agreement
is a whole new world in terms of
building trust in terms of negotiating
with communities and I think when one of
the papers that you were given you
really see that you know sometimes this
trust can be rather personal and so
people feel you know it takes time of
course you can do that in a
paternalistic way and so sometimes even
the project can be a little hindered by
the absence of a person if the trust is
very much associated with that person I
think one of the main issues remain
funding this is nothing new we often
fund
raised for our projects and you know
they're the fact that we don't have a
stream reliable or consistent funding is
certainly a major limitation of this
project but so is the fact that in often
cases we focus very much about only one
aspect of the area and not you know only
for example focus only on one you know
the biodiversity but not on other the
other benefits that could make the
project more viable in the long term
this is basically what I'd like to say I
think there's quite a bit of information
and I apologize for having packed so
much but I certainly hope that we can
talk and once again what I presented
here is not only my work but the work of
a lot of Mike you know a lot of people
were closely with so in many cases
should you have a specific question i'll
be more than happy to put you in contact
with with my colleagues and I guess and
this is it thank you very much